Hey, just as a change of pace, a little levity,
this is kind of funny and interesting.
Many of you know that on this program I've
been smeared by homophobic people for a long
time because I support LGBT rights.
We also have funny stories like when producer
Louis was the producer of the David Pakman
show, I got an email from, uh, from a gentleman
saying, Hey David, it's so great that you
and your partner, uh, are doing a show together.
Um, how long have you and Louis been together?
My husband and I would love to have you guys
over our place for dinner.
And as funny as the idea was, if not telling
Lewis the pretense and going over as a supposed
coupled to dinner at someone's house, we didn't
do that.
And I clarified Lewis and I are not only not
together, we exclusively date women.
I am personally not gay, but I support gay
rights.
I'm a straight ally.
We've been straight allies on this program
for more than a decade.
But over the years there have been both misunderstandings
and smears about this.
So one example is that a few years ago I was
featured in a documentary called Minnesota
nice.
Uh, the documentary is about anti-gay bullying
suicides and that's a horribly tragic subject.
But I was featured as a gay teen who committed
suicide after being bullied.
And I had to clarify, I'm not a teenager,
I'm not gay, I wasn't bullied and I'm alive.
And it has been brought to my attention that
once again there is a reference on my Wikipedia
page to I suppose that relationship with a
man.
Check this out.
This was added to the personal life section
recently saying quote, in November, 2015,
Pacman moved to New York city, breaking up
with his longterm male partner, which go incited
with a relocation of the David Pakman show
his production.
This one is subtle, but someone did add a
note that said citation needed.
Apparently they realized there was no citation
for that claim and they've not been able to
find one because it is a completely bogus
claim, so it would be inappropriate for me
to go in and edit the Wikipedia page.
The subjects of Wiki pages aren't supposed
to edit those pages themselves.
I think that makes a lot of sense.
Could be a conflict of interest, but I'm asking
for your help to update my Wikipedia page
and also help expand it.
I feel like it could be far more robust based
on what the David Pakman show has become over
the years.
This is funny in a way, but the obsession
with smearing me as a gay man is not only
sort of getting boring, I don't actually understand
the obsession with it.
Like what is so appealing about that?
Maybe somebody can explain it to me.
Sunday is my birthday.
We've got a huge membership special.
All right.
Police came to my house yesterday and they
said, we are not here to take any action today,
but we heard you are planning a crazy membership
special on Sunday.
Just know we've been made aware of it and
we're going to monitor in case the special
is too deep of a discount.
A Sunday, get on our mailing list today@davidpakman.com
put in your email address on Sunday.
You will get an email with this incredible,
incredible membership special.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
the Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this